welcome to this video playing The Jug
jugulator jugulator is this
right okay he's uh a greedy person
taking a Pawn on move too but okay at
least he returned it quickly so uh other
words we have the Queen's Gambit
accepted let's see um that's really a
weak spot in my
repertoire I don't uh know it too well I
don't have a really great line against
it but okay this looks it looks quite
quite
okay I have D5 now in the
mix and
um I think this is even a theoretical
[Music]
position um
yeah I want to do C4
obviously Bishop
A3
C4 yeah he can maybe really take
it it looks it looks a little bit sick
but maybe he
can yeah maybe just
this it's not so easy for black here to
conveniently
develop Bishop D7 I'm going to take the
pawn yeah okay here I'm going C4 what
I'm not sure about is how exactly to
proceed maybe here
so that after Bishop D7 I have D5 yeah
the question is do I play D5 or how do I
continue
here yeah probably
D5 that should be should be the right
continuation okay he's just
grabbing
[Music]
okay
so Bishop uh
[Music]
F4 yeah Bishop F4 Bishop E5 is not that
terrible for
black
yeah that's
true
H yeah okay it's not such a great
position really for
white I don't really see a great
continuation here
[Music]
okay if he takes I have Bishop F4 to
play D6 it should give me some
compensation and um I'm intending H5 H6
here it's um yeah it's difficult to find
something
here he's just ignoring
everything not a bad move I'm
not saying that
[Music]
okay now I can
take okay let's push this
up there's some there are some ideas
here connected
to to F7 maybe if I get to I want to
play
D6 is there some way to get this in
D6
like Bishop G5 somehow to E7 is this
kind of
idea I don't see
[Music]
it okay I'm a bit worried that he will
play
A5
okay I think this helped me now we can
really never move the queen but A5 A4 is
a little bit
worrisome I I
thought my Bishop is
somewhat somewhat less perpose not very
very good not very well
[Music]
placed
okay where are you what are you doing
here
want to go to C2 or I don't don't really
don't really get
it
maybe but I have Rook
C1 okay let's I just push this back come
on and uh maybe
[Music]
here he decided on that really really
quickly so let's see is there something
I can do
here I
mean Bishop G5 E7 is the the general
idea pretty much down on the
clock it's not so
good
H um I'm kind of surprised that he can
ignore
that time
warning um yeah
so taking that the problem is I have
only 50 seconds and the position is not
that
[Music]
easy
check and now it's it it gets much
easier as ick will
promote black resigns yeah it was was
kind of weird I really I really don't
think I'm I'm in I'm so great here it
looked nice at first I'm I'm sort of
welld developed and have the D Pawn but
but how do I actually break this maybe I
should just play Bishop F4 I mean this
is probably very debatable what I did
here not terrible
but it's not helping me let's
say yeah the computer is giving A5 the
move that I was worried about
and this is really a bit of an annoying
move yeah black is fine here so at least
the computer is giving black a an edge
here slide
Edge yeah and after that it still should
be okay I don't know this this was all a
little
bit little bit risky but here I feel
okay again I don't know I'm not sure
about
F5 here it it's starts to get
tricky
yeah computer's evaluation is going up
up up up to more than one Pawn now yeah
Bishop B7 is very very much of a problem
and he ran right into
[Music]
it and rookie one Rook Rook e one is the
big
problem yeah and here I'm just I'm just
promoting the thing yeah he didn't
didn't defend um very well here to be to
be um to be honest but um it was a very
tricky position beforehand okay I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching